there's an interesting new piece to the
joe rogan vaccine covid controversy that
i want to talk about and
it's it's sort of a common
endpoint that often takes place when
someone
makes a bunch of statements or allows
statements to be made and those state
statements are then scrutinized then it
turns out while these statements are
inaccurate they're they're potentially
dangerous etc there's this common
refrain which is some version
of nobody should really be listening to
me about this topic anyway and that's
where joe rogan has reportedly landed
saying taking advice from him on
vaccines
isn't a smart thing to do and while it
might be funny and it's certainly true
a lot of the problem comes from
this sort of like moral hazard type
scenario although moral hazard's not the
exact word for it but but some will know
what i mean
where
those who need to be told that it's not
smart to take their advice on x
are people
not smart enough to realize that and and
that's really sort of what's at issue
here so let me back up a little bit and
remind you guys a podcaster and comedian
joe rogan has been over the last three
weeks or so
i've been under heavy fire
for two different sets of reasons one
comes with regard to
covet and vaccine disinformation uh
perpetuated by some of joe joe rogan's
guests with no disclaimers that what the
guests are saying runs counter not only
to the medical science consensus but to
the empirical realities
of medical science some such uh claims
have also been made by rogan himself and
this led to one controversy wherein neil
young and joni mitchell and others
pulled their content from spotify and
protest spotify the kind of main
platform for joe rogan's podcast
separately but relatedly there has also
been significant uh backlash
against joe rogan for numerous uses uses
of the n-word on his program over the
last decade um
some uh jokes and laughing related to
sexual harassment and sexual assault and
so that that's another problem today
we're focusing on the vaccine piece and
there's a new report from mediaite which
says joe rogan says people who take the
vaccine take vaccine advice from him are
not smart are not smart
um
joe rogan made his way back to the
stand-up stage tuesday night and
addressed the spotify controversies
according to the hollywood reporter
rogan headlined a small show in austin
texas at the vulcan gas company and
talked about the controversies um
speaking about the n-word he said i used
to say it if i was talking about a
richard pryor bit or something i would
say it in context
somebody made a compilation of every
time i said it over 14 years and they
put it on youtube and it turned out that
was racist as f even to me
i'm me and i'm watching it saying stop
saying it i put my cursor over the video
and i'm like four more minutes i haven't
used that word in years but it's kind of
weird people will get really mad if you
use that uh word and tweet about it on a
phone that's made by slaves rogan then
tackled the other controversy the
anti-vaxx he says i talk s for a living
that's why this is so baffling if you're
taking vaccine advice from me is that
really my fault what dumb s were you
about to do when my stupid idea sounded
better you know that dude who made
people eat animal penises on tv how does
he feel about medicine if you want my
advice don't take my advice rogan
previously said dozens of celebrities
contacted him for covet advice including
aaron rodgers and ufc president dana
white so this is this is the exact
problem guys the problem is
people are not
uh smart enough to realize that they
should not be taking his vaccine advice
the the people we're worried about is
the point and that's why it's so
concerning right if joe rogan was only
giving vaccine advice
to informed people
it would essentially have no detrimental
effect you'll be like yeah okay nobody
nobody's taking that seriously uh he's
also by the way kind of calling his
audience dumb which is interesting they
may not realize that that's what he's
doing i don't know
um but but this whole like come on guys
who would believe me
it's a very common kind of face saving
tactic for people pushing these
narratives but at the end of the day
it's really an insult to his audience
you guys aren't so stupid you would
listen to me right and unfortunately the
answer is yes a lot of them are
a lot of them are and it's evidenced by
the fact that dana white is coming to uh
rogan for advice
aaron rodgers said on other podcasts
when i got covered i talked to joe rogan
and there's this entire echo chamber
that reinforces the idea that you would
go to him i think it was um
there's this
um oh man there's this right-wing
trump-supporting podcaster named tim
poole who i guess said you know he used
to be on the left i guess or something
like that and when tim poole got coveted
he said he called rogan so it's not you
know um
it's not only that rogan needs to let
the audience know i guess it's not
you're not smart if you listen to me on
this
there's other people who are then saying
i'm also going to rogan for advice on
this stuff and that's why it's so
concerning now the the fallback of
saying your audience is stupid for
listening to you it's interesting for
sure
uh and it i mean i don't know what it
i'm not sure what it suggests about what
joe rogan thinks about his own audience
uh because if joe rogan is saying it's
not smart to take advice from me
he must know lots of people are doing it
what does he think about his audience
which is an interesting question as as
well but this is sometimes you know it's
it's a version of
when fox news gets sued for the things
that tucker carlson says on his show
the lawyers for fox say
carlson is an entertainer who engages in
hyperbole
he's not saying things that should be
taken as fact he's not a reporter
but the whole shtick with fox is
report opinions and frame and package
this stuff as if it is someone telling
you these are facts but when it comes to
the legal defense that's what they go to
alex jones we know that alex jones own
lawyer or lawyers when he has been sued
say this is an entertainer he's doing a
character here the things he says are in
character it's it's almost like they
liken it to you know when uh
i don't know
when uh when rufus sewell plays
a nazi in man in the high castle
that's not what rufus sewell believes
it's his character and like we all get
it when we're watching man in the high
castle but it's deliberately
uh uh kind of
obfuscated when it's tucker carlson or
when it's it's alex jones and uh joe
rogan's using a different version of
that he's not saying i'm playing a
character he's just saying it should be
obvious that it's not smart to listen to
me about this stuff but it's not obvious
to the very people who are actually
going to listen and say oh ivermectin or
no vaccines or whatever the case may be
so a common refrain
that often kind of comes at the end
of these controversies and it seems that
that's sort of where joe rogan has
landed